what I've deliberately done is you'll
get questions and they're more or less
be a paragraph okay because they are not
giving you this right they're like okay
we have all of this extra padding around
so I'm just sort of this is an example 1
i'm just trying to blow away or that and
give the most essential details and you
will have examples when you open up will
do the first question together in the
exercise I've got this example a second
one and then we'll do that is our third
one together you need to blow away all
those bits and sort of see through to
the important done I went used to this
with projectile motion is super harmonic
okay so you have to look for the
important details I've got an object
particle body you'll see all of those
used interchangeably its mass is four
kilos they tell you about it's the force
acting on that object and in this
question they've said that the direction
of the force isn't changing okay so
that's kind of nice because you might
have something that's moving around
exerting a force and that's confusing
that changes things quite drastically so
there are force here acting in the same
direction you got an initial velocity
and it's going in the same direction as
the force the question is can you find
out how fast it's going at time after
four seconds because you can see that's
the humid deal ok now the reason why we
started with onions laws and those I'm
understanding forces is particularly
particularly this guy right this will
often be your very first line of working
and you just have to interpret this in
your particular situation okay so here
comes my solution the first thing I'm
gonna write is there it was them hey now
you think yourself how much of this how
much of this do I know right and where
am I going okay so when you have a look
there are some easy to pick out for
example there's mass there so i can
substitute that innocent there's a force
there so that's going to go over here
what's unknown is the acceleration now
think before we actually start to
compute what am i going to do with this
to try and answer the question
give you a hint now trying to go to the
loss is how I'm going to get there to do
it yeah fantastic I'm going to get this
is a DV DT right so eventually I'm going
to get an expression here that I can
integrate and then I'll get some my
velocity function does that make sense
ok so I've now got a trajectory roughly
puffed out in my mind let's have a go
like this so I'm a left hand side I've
got the force 12 t take away 3 d squared
you have to pay attention on this is
just an interesting example but clearly
you can see the force is given to you in
terms of time might not be my give begin
in terms of displacement or something
else in terms of velocity would be the
obvious thing if you had air resistance
from the lunatic water totemo suit is
where there's the force acting on my
object over here I've got mass times
acceleration so in my mass I like to
choose to write acceleration in a feelin
it makes it easiest for me to get to be
so we've got all this horse which would
you like to the other tiers perfect okay
looking good so I'm just going to
rearrange slightly let's make DB DT the
subject I'd letters 1/4 while I'm at it
so that leaves me with all the ratings
i3t I could do by off 30-3 for this
season okay lovely so I've now got an
expression for DV energy so all I need
to do to get to be is to integrate okay
so that's why i'm going to say v is
equal to and I've got my integral 0
okay the reason I'm doing this is
because I'm putting I'm trying to climb
out from this second derivative up to a
first derivative now I will point out as
well at this point i can either solve
this by an indefinite integral or a
definite integral right if i do it this
way i'm going to have a constant how am
I going to deal with that constant what
I use okay I've got an initial velocity
so time 0 V goes to be fine if I wanted
to I'm not going to pursue it this time
but how what kind of definitely jewelr
fall in order to solve this out what
would you suggest when so because maybe
you integrate it from so if you went
back one step and you went integral
right when the when v is equal to 0 0 no
sorry when v is equal to 2 t is equal to
0 right hand side so you went beyond the
top and two on the bottom so i have this
yeah and then equals to integral T on
the top and 0 on the bottom because too
when t is equal 0 initial velocities too
okay yeah I'm not going to go down this
life for now you're welcome to have a go
with that right now if you like because
I think it's very simple to do it this
way like I don't need to put my head
heading huggers however i'll just point
out like this is kind of nice if you can
conceptually wrap your head around it
because i can do another one here right
like i don't have to do this then get
closer then put it back in this can you
see what he's done he's got his values
that why not right just got to be
careful with your various for that's why
I'm sort of like hmm be careful with
that so I'm going to just put this stuff
off to one side okay let's just pursue
this because this is really simple
what's the integral what's the primitive
function get out of this career into T
spread
for Falls area that's okay great so I've
integrated successfully and now like you
suggested I'm going to use my initial
condition so when the where T equals 0
equals 2 and you can clearly see the
constant yeah ik plus all these terms
again and vanish so therefore and we're
going to go ahead because I think you
guys get it I don't even watch v I would
be when T equals hawk so I'm going to go
straight there okay via for is going to
be 3 on 2 times 16 minus a quarter x
plus 2 that's 3 times 8 which is 24
verse 16 that's too i get this is 10 yep
me mr. say so my velocity is in meters
per second okay this is an easy question
okay great question so do i need to stay
which way this is going ok now when you
have a look at the weather i set this up
for you this load up down there right
okay so what you've got is like positive
direction negative direction i have gone
through and I've got my sign out of this
I think the safest way to answer this
it's the same therefore the velocity
years 10 meters per second in the
positive direction however i'm just
going to point out if I was marketing
for question obvious and I saw this I
give them a big tip on a question as
simple as this that'd be fine okay
because you can clearly see like I set
this off this question super bare-bones
you didn't even have to decide like was
up positive or down positive like we'll
have a look at those in a second so I'm
not so worried about the direction this
question is can you work out how do you
this can you integrate successfully
that's this question is about so if I
saw that Debbie comes up